ça fait 20 ans que la lune a été touchée
il ya l'électricité qu'une heure par
jour à peine de quoi manger tout ce qui
vous intéressent celles que ce mot vol
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention téléportation d'énergie
son pouvoir est incroyable au delà de
tout ce que j'ai pu voir tout ce que
nous avons c'est le moment présent je
vous aime bien
j'ai attendu sans cet endroit rend tout
le monde un peu nerveux et pas peur je
n'ai plus dangereux qu'il n'y paraît
toutes les difficultés que la terre a
connu ces 20 dernières années sont le
résultat de la guerre avec thierno est
sur le point d'aller jouer au football
avec ce qui est en fait une bombe
nucléaire et
parce que c'est juste un jeu c'est bien
ça c'est à peu près ça les plus faciles
de risquer sa vie quand on sait qu'on
est soutenue par des millions de
personnes
même si elles ne connaissent pas la
vérité ou ne comprennent pas le risque
quatre jeunes terriens avec des pouvoirs
incroyables vous montrer qu'il existe
quelque chose qui peut les inspirer
je vais pas faire long vous inquiétez
pas il ya environ un mois
sonia m'a dit tu es censé durer combien
de temps une pause je me suis promis de
ne pas contacter sonia et puis
aujourd'hui les cracks et ça fait une
rose qu'elle a lu mon message et qu'elle
a toujours pas répondu et pour ne rien
arranger je suis coincé un repas
familial où la conversation tourne
actuellement autour et ses surfaces au
sol
intéressant et toi de rien tu en penses
quoi
vous me demandez ce que je pense du
chauffage au sol alors que j'ai envoyé
un message à 17h24 et que j'ai toujours
pas de réponse foutez moi la paix merde
j'adorerais pouvoir répondre un truc
comme ça je crois que ça ferait très
plaisir à ta soeur si tu faisais un
petit discours le jour de la cérémonie
oh [ __ ] je l'avais pas vu venir celle
là pourtant ça fait trois mois que je me
prépare au cauchemar de ce mariage à
l'église
le vin d'honneur et surtout la chenille
c'est une machine à broyer les orgueils
ce soir c'est la meilleure chose qui
puisse arriver ce discours pardon mais
c'est très bon a marre de l'image pour
la toile dans cette famille n'a pas raté
de faire du bruit c'est super
désagréable en fait je m'amuse car c'est
une excellente à yalta gueule ta gueule
tellement de choses à dire [ __ ] merde
pardon des choses qu'on ne dit jamais
parce qu'on pense que c'est trop tard
mais en fait je crois qu'il n'est jamais
trop tard
et c'est cadeau
c'est ce casse la gueule ça veut dire
qu'on passera méfiance au hockey
on sort et chris henry foss
absorbée
[Musique]
dans mon
mais voilà
[Musique]
idra
un week-end
moi
économique au foot ce jeu
[Musique]
mt pris l'habitude d'y oreilles
m
[Musique]
wilfrid adamu soma
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
deux fois l'arrière de sa voiture
sur la plage trois fois deux voies la
nuit et une en plein jour dans les dunes
sous la douche du camping une fois
[Musique]
j'avale
c'est ça
c'est
si vous regardez ceci si vous avez reçu
un calendrier de l'avent respecter les
règles
[Musique]
serbie tu fais là joyeux anniversaire
calendrier de l'avent
respecte toutes les règles jusqu'à
l'ouverture de la dernière fenêtre sinon
je te tue alors on avale un faux les
avaler tous jésus dit au paralytique qui
lève toi et marche devrait arrêter avec
ce calendrier safa 35
tu prends bien tes médoc contre 2
hallucinations toucha j'ai marché
je marchais
[Musique]
tu devrais arrêter d'avaler toutes ces
saloperies
tout calendrier végétaux tout se greffer
trois personnes rentrant mourir
cette nuit tu me fous la paix
[Musique]
baby just holding a craché
on a une ressortissante été arrêté cette
nuit c'est quoi une affaire de drogue
non son mari a été assassiné en plein
mariage
[Musique]
tu te souviens de quoi tu noir
en fait vous vouliez pas de ce mariage
c'est ça pas comme ça et à celle où vous
avez pourrit la vie avec vos croyances
d'homère
peux pas la laisser comme ça et personne
dans sa famille n'est capable de la
protéger
hachette ou lite gratuite
si tu veux la vérité c'est ce qu'il faut
faire
vous croyez comprendre et vous ne
comprenez rien
powermat cha cha
[ __ ] votre nouvelle scierie créations
originales possession seulement sur
canal+